hello everyone
and welcome to our brand spanking new
ninja house in cambridge
i wanted to give you an update on the
work so far for senua saga hellblade 2.
what we're doing right now is building a
good chunky slice of the game before we
then move into full production to build
out the rest
hellblade was very special for us and we
didn't want to do a straight sequel we
wanted to do something extra special
and so we're making our lives as
difficult as possible
in that pursuit the game is set in
iceland 9th century iceland
so we've been sending our arts and audio
teams out there
doing photography photogrammetry and
combining it with satellite data
to recreate large swathes of the
landscape
on the character front we're building
real costumes
scanning them in we're collaborating
with epic games
to bring you next generation digital
characters
on the combat front we want it to be
extra real and brutal
and so molina our main actress has been
training for two years and
all of our animators have undergone
combat training
and so what you're going to see here is
not a trailer it's not a gameplay reveal
but rather a montage of the kind of work
we've been up to
hope you like it
[Music]
will you follow me
on this journey
[Music]
by sea
[Music]
by land
and dreams through the valleys of
despair
over the mountains of rage to the depths
of fear
in my mind you might see me as
weak but i
will show you what lies behind my eyes
with our sword
we will forge new stories
to strike the gods that haunt us
we will embrace our suffering
soothe our scars of grief
and break their siege of our minds
they may see them as gods
but we
we will show them what lies behind our
eyes
foreign